[Music]
show of hands who's heard of Google Maps
what a shock but show of hands for who
has heard a flutter okay I don't even
know why we're giving this talk but how
many of you have an app in production or
near going into production there's a few
so we're gonna do two things today the
first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna give a quick world wind tour a
flutter why we think it's good for
building apps and we're gonna take a
little peek under the hood we'll do that
for about 10 15 minutes and then what
we're gonna do is we are going to well
Brett's going to do some live coding and
sling some code on stage and he's going
to combine two of his favorite things
which are ice cream and maps no sorry it
is actually ice cream in maps there we
go and live coding is always much more
exciting for you possibly not for us so
we're gonna get through the sites very
quickly and then we'll get into the meat
and the bones of the topic okay so for
those of you who may not know they're
very few of you in the audience what is
flutter well flutter lets you build this
this is a app runs an iOS and Android
and it's built from a single codebase
but if you take it look at the app it's
not your standard out-of-the-box buttons
and drop downs and app bars and
everything else it has a pretty unique
UI and it's got some pretty interesting
animations and really that's what
flutter is about it's not about building
your standard clone of an email app or
building that chat app that looks like
every other chat app it's about building
apps that could look like other apps but
give you the power to be able to
customize and to create something that
you when your designers would want so
let's take a few let's take a quick look
at why we think flutter is good for
doing these types of things
well first off and you can see the term
native here a lot it's very overloaded
so I'll try to be
they can hear when I'm talking about
native you eyes I'm talking about for
those of you with iPhones when you're
scrolling something your scrolling
behavior is gonna feel like your iPhone
it's gonna drop down a bit it's kind of
bounce back up again and for those of
you on Android it's gonna have that
little inkwell effect and when you
navigate from screen to screen the two
platforms behave differently and so
that's what we mean by native UX native
UI and on each of those devices and
flutter gives you this out of the box
this is the same app same codebase but
you see they are behaving in different
ways they're behaving appropriately to
the platform on which they are running
and you get this out of the box and
flutter takes care of it for you
quick interesting fact everything you
see here and in every flutter app
flutter is rendering 100% of the pixels
on screen which means the buttons and
the app bars they're not rendered by
Android they're not rendered by iOS
they're rendered by flutter and we have
built a large collection of widgets to
enable you to do this and I'll explain
more why we did that a little bit so we
got native UI so that's great what we
also have is we have fluid and custom
UI's and this is one of the reasons why
we control the rendering because since
we've built our own approximations of
non approximations our own
implementations of the material design
spec
and apples UI specification which we
call Cupertino we are able to not only
implement these but give you the ability
to heavily customize them if you so
desire and on top of that because we
control the rendering we're able to
optimize these to be able to give you
the animations and the 60 frames per
second that you would expect this is
kind of a no-brainer if you've got one
code base and you're building for two
platforms you know you're gonna get half
the cost if the time is equivalent
there's gonna cost you less money but
that's not really the point here because
one of the things that we have done and
what we realized is that giving you an
SDK out-of-the-box is only half the
story
because for developers what you need is
a really good set of tools to be able to
build apps or software effectively and
so we have built a suite of tools and
the one you see up here is heart reload
where when you edit a piece of code and
when
save it it is deployed and render to the
device on which you're testing being an
emulator an actual device plugged in in
near-real-time a second two seconds
maybe less than a second and so your
development cycle is very very very
iterative and how does this translate
into what we in Google have experienced
well there is an app in Google that we
converted from iOS and Android to
flutter took about three or four weeks
to get engineers up to speed and the
flutter framework to understand it and
once they did and started to
re-implement the app and then get to the
point where the app was implement and
add new features it was reported via
metrics cuz we're Google Data we
autofill to gather a lot of it and when
we looked at it we saw that the
developers were about two to three times
more productive versus just one platform
alone and on top of that they also got
the other platform included in that so
we saw really significant productivity
games which is why flutter or which is
why Google invest and flutter because we
get and see real benefits from that so
there we go there's you know a little
bit of marketing spiel about why you
should use Fleur that's great but let's
look under the hood a little bit and see
how some of these things come to pass
well first of all flutters tech stack
the entire UI stack is built in the dart
language there are many reasons why we
use dart and I'll cover a few of them
later on but we have built the entire UI
stack at dart and because flutter is
open source all your developers have
full access to the source code of that
UI which are those UI elements which
means you can go in you can see how we
implemented a button and you can take
that and you can change it you can
modify it you can build your own and be
inspired by it or do something different
but the entire source code is it's like
having the blueprint in front of you to
be able to implement your own UI tools
as well as that you see we have layered
it which means if you want material or
you want Cupertino out of the box just
use the widgets that we give you but if
you want to go a little lower and you
want to change the buttons to be a
little different or your app bar to
behave differently you can drop down a
layer and you can customize their or you
can drop further play around with the
different animations or drop even
further and handle all the painting and
rendering yourself which is why with
flutter it is very straightforward to be
a
to customize to a very high degree your
UI so that's great we our engine is
built in C++ and it runs on the skia
rendering engine which is an open source
project and other projects such as
chromium use it and so we use this this
is a highly optimized engine for drawing
2d graphics and it is available across a
large number of platforms and the reason
why we use it is because there is a
great implementation of skier for
Android a great implementation of skier
for iOS that we can compile to we can
compile to them but because we have an
engine embedder we can potentially
deploy to other platforms so there is an
experimental engine and better for
flutter for Mac OS which you can go and
get on our wiki I think it's on the
github it's only get up there is a great
post we did a medium which describes how
to build an engine and better for Linux
so flutter at the moment we're focusing
on mobile we're making sure the Android
and iOS experiences are great but there
is the potential to have flutter run on
other platforms as well another reason
why we use Dart we didn't just pick it
out of a hat and go through the door
language we'll use that one of the
reasons why we did it is dart has a
great compiler chain and so what that
means is when I showed you heart reload
earlier and you're gonna see Bart use
that heavily you saw code change and
then the actual implementation of the
app change on the device in near real
time and the reason we can do that is
because dart has a virtual machine and
when you're in debug mode we can take
your app put it on the phone we can take
your virtual machine put it on the flow
and every time you change your code we
can inject that code straight into the
virtual machine and boom it's running in
the device that sounds wonderful but
virtual machines come at a cost in terms
of performance and come at a cost in
terms of the size of your app which
isn't ideal when you're going to be
deploying to production but dart gives
us other means of being able to compile
this so that was our giad implementation
we have ahead of time compiler which
will take your flutter and dart code and
will compile it down to native machine
code on the device we have our machine
code and IO
and Android and it is running on the
bare metal we don't need a VM at that
point we don't need a lot of the tooling
we've built for debugging and profiling
your app we strip it all out and it
becomes much much smaller so you get the
best of both worlds
dart gives us the ability to go hey give
us an amazing developer experience and
hey streamline us to the nth degree so
we can run as fast as we can for users
in production and developer tools if you
use Android studio IntelliJ fantastic
plug-in we maintain it ourselves
if you use like myself Visual Studio
code fantastic plug-in which maintain
ourselves but the infrastructure we've
built for these platforms is available
to other developers so if you want to go
out there and build a a integration for
vim which has been done by some of the
engineers in the flutter team or you
want to build it for Emacs or any of the
other IDE s that's entirely possible
we have full terminal support for those
who like to live in the command line for
those who like to have continuous
integration servers I mentioned a hot
reload and we have a great package
manager so when you're pulling in your
first party in third-party packages and
libraries and plugins we were able to
take care of the versioning pull in the
right pieces for you to make that happen
we have platform channels which allows
you to integrate with existing Android
and iOS code be a Java Kotlin Swift and
object I got them all objective-c and we
can go the other way and you can add
flutter to existing apps so for those of
you out there who got this sounds
fantastic photos great but we've already
invested years of time building our apps
on both platforms you were able to
integrate that and we've seen a lot of
people take that route where they have a
small portion of their app and flutter
they tied into their existing apps then
over time
they can transfer more or less of it
into flutter and still get for at least
that portion a single code base on which
to run it I'm gonna very quickly talk
about how you eyes are composed because
Bret's gonna be diving through a bunch
of code and I just want to give you a
flavor now so you don't get lost in the
rush here is an app it's got some images
and some icons and whatnot but how is
flutter actually how are you is it
or how are your developers get a build
for this well let's take a look okay so
these things seem to be laid out
vertically to begin with so flutter has
a concept of a column and we can wrap
our UI widgets in a column and here's
the thing pretty much everything in
flutter bar a few exceptions are widgets
and typically when you think of widgets
you go UI components button at bar icon
text but in flutter layout is also a
widget so we in your code you're
actually defining the layout which can
be jarring for people who are coming
from excuse-me coming from things like
sam'l on windows or xml layouts in
android because you used to that
separation but what we found is because
of the way dart structures its code and
because of the way the flutter SDK is
structured it is actually very readable
and very maintainable and gives you
things like heart reload and very
maintainable for the code given so there
we go
vertical wrapping in a column that's
great well the thing at the top of the
column is probably an image that's not
too interesting but then we take a look
at this and this is kind of interesting
there's a few things going in here so
let's take a closer look so it looks
like we have our text on one side and we
have an icon and a number on the other
side so you know that's a horizontal
layout we can wrap that in a row it
looks like our text expands to fill the
space so we can wrap that in and expand
it and then if you think about the text
there's one on top of the other
internally in that we can then wrap it
in a column so you've got columns and
rows and columns and we have things like
stacks and these may seem like very
primitive compared to potentially some
of the other types of layouts you get
elsewhere but we've found that just
using these primitives and using them
cleverly we are able to construct very
sophisticated UIs from these and it's
very straightforward to do that so when
you look at it all you really have here
is a column of things and then when you
come down to your third row for example
it looks like you have a row of icons
and each of those is a column with one
of the other and that's how we build
things up we compose our UI elements
together and we lay them out
with the same code we have a full set
implementation of material design for
flutter unsurprisingly
in fact our material design spec is
highly inclusive we pretty much cover
everything that the spec defines so you
can go in and you can build material
design style apps very very easily and
because the new material design is
designed to be fairly flexible flutter
is ideally placed to give you that
flexibility to be able to customize and
tweak these but sometimes you just want
to build an app that looks more like a
standard iOS app which is why
out-of-the-box
we also offer what we call cupertino
widgets which will let you compose
things and put things together in terms
of more of Apple style of widgets and
you can mix and match these and you can
use one or the other we're not you know
we we don't specify it's it's it's
all-or-nothing
but we give you these out-of-the-box so
you have complete choice as to how you
want to build your apps two or three
more slides and then Brett's on
spotlight but I want to talk very
briefly about cross-platform and our
ecosystem so as I mentioned if you have
a clump of Kotlin code or Java code and
you have a bunch of Swift code and
you're like I've spent ages building
this code it does a lot of the business
logic it's fundamental to my business I
don't want to rewrite this but I would
really love to use some of flutters UI
capabilities or extend it with flutter
and dart you can do that so we have the
ability to be able to do cross-platform
RPC in both directions and even have
event channels so you can stream events
in one direction or the other so you can
have Android and iOS code talk to
flutter code and as I said you can do it
in the other direction as well we also
have a great ecosystem of packages some
of which we maintain ourselves like
firebase plugins are us the webview and
maps plugins are us we do camera we do a
bunch of things that we feel are
critical for the platform but the
community has stepped up and added tons
of other packages and plugins out there
and you can go to that website in fact
you can just do flutter packages google
that and you will get to this site and
you can just see the range of packages
they're available to you out of the box
which will you know save you time
building but the idea here is is that
darts been around for a while flutters
fairly new but we already have a rich
ecosystem of dart code and our flutter
ecosystem is is growing steadily to the
point where we have over 1400 flutter
packages in our in our pub system today
flutter is completely open-source every
line of code is in github comm flutter
flutter or github comm flutter engine
you can go there you can see how
everything is built and we take
contributions externally all the time
there's over 300 contributors to the
flutter repository and code base itself
in fact we've gotten so popular that
we're ranked pretty highly now in terms
of popularity for github repos there are
thousands of apps written and flutter
that have been published to the Play
Store and the App Store google has
published a few the community has
published thousands more will show you
will give you a taste of who's doing
what towards the end but flutter is
ready for use in production today it has
been for a long time the like the app we
always used to talk about Hamilton is
like a year and a half more since it was
first put out there and since then we've
gone to beta we're at one da o what not
to at the moment I believe and so we
have a solid stable platform that we and
Google rely on and that we feel that you
can rely on to provide services to your
users our community is awesome we love
our community they're very inclusive and
they have a ton of areas in which you
can start with flutter if you go to
flutter dev slash community we have a
bunch of community links there they do
things like start flutter calm floated
on Institute we have fantastic
documentation I feel on flutter dev the
community has produced so much more so
if you want to learn about flutter there
is some starting points but I think I
have waffle on enough so without further
ado what could possibly go wrong with
your life coding demo so if we could
transfer to the demo computer let's see
how much before like am making myself on
stage
here we go so here we are we're starting
with your traditional hello world app
what we're going to build today is a an
application to let us roam around the
ice cream stalls of San Francisco it
seems like a great idea while I was
sweltering away in the Australian heat
but now that I've come to San Francisco
and it's all kinds of cold and I'm sort
of like I should have done coffee
instead yeah there's a reason why I have
my wooly hat on today yeah totally so
growing up in Australia ice cream stores
use this palette of pastel colors and so
blue and white it's not really doing it
for me so the first thing we're going to
change is we're going to change the the
colour and what you've seen there is
I've made a change to the code saved it
to disc flutter has noticed and there's
hot reloaded the app as you saw it's
pretty quick so the obvious question is
if I've got a list of ice cream stores
where are we going to store it well
being a cloud conference of course I'm
going to go with Google Cloud firestorm
and the first step in including
functionality is we imported at the top
of the file now the next step is I'm
going to turn around and make a quick
change to the application and something
really amazing is going to happen you
are well done congratulations round of
applause from okay I've done yeah yeah
there we go
so before we we run away in horror it's
actually trying to tell us something
interesting type homepage is not a
subtype of stateless widget so what's
happened here is initially this was a
stateless widget I'm hoping that wasn't
my phone beeping anyway it was a
stateless widget and we've turned it
into a stateful widget because I need it
to actually have some state and flutter
has gone I can't quite figure out what
you're doing here helped me out here and
a fairly easy way of helping it out he's
turning around and reloading it and
we're up and running again again
reloading is takes longer than
sorry am i using my phrasing correctly
relighting is a bit bit slower but not
that slow so one of the things to see
here is is that like the app broke and
didn't it's not immediately obvious why
and that's because one of the benefits
of heart reload is that it maintains
state so if you're five screens down in
your app and you're tweaking your UI on
whatnot you don't have to renew gate
back there every time you save your code
what happened here though is is that
bread actually changed the code which
maintains the state and once you do that
flutter is not smart enough to kind of
go I'm going to met automatically make
your state recover and so we have to do
a hot restart which is you know a second
and a half versus seven hundred
milliseconds but it kills your state
cool so the reason I did this is that
I'm actually doing the idiomatic thing
when creating state I'm creating a
stateful object and so homepage is a
stateful widget and it has a partner
object called homepage state and when
this object is created it's turning
around and making a connection to fire
store and we're doing a query against
fire store we're looking at the
collection of ice cream stores and
ordering them by their name now that
I've got this this query I can actually
turn around and start using it so what
I'm doing is I've got a stream builder
I passed that stream builder my stream
and a stream for those of you aren't
aware it's kind of the love child of
futures and lists where it's this list
that goes off into the future and each
future state is actually a state of the
database so if someone makes a change in
the cloud fire store adds another ice
cream store it will turn around and
update the app and we'll go from 14 ice
cream stores to 15 so one of the things
that people might see here is like this
seems a little complicated with streams
and asynchronous what are they talking
about one of the strengths of Dart and
one of the strengths of flutter is it's
asynchronous in its very nature it means
you don't have to spin up threads to
handle things like network calls and
whatnot or to handle like
I owe basically and what you can do with
it is it's very easy for Bret and a few
lines of code here to say here is a
stream of data from fire store here is a
stream builder and this app with a few
lines of code will update itself every
time that data store changes so if we go
in and we add new things to the database
that's going to be reflected in the app
automatically and it will rebuild itself
with no additional work from you yes and
of course by knowing you that you're all
quite interested in ice cream stores I
went ahead and did the next step which
is instead of just saying we've got 14
stores I turned around and I've created
a ListView and so we've got this list
view here I've got a bunch of stores
he's a part of dart syntax that I quite
like we have a theme called named
constructors
so I'm constructing an object called
ListView but I'm constructing it in a
specific way
where I give it a builder so I'm
effectively creating the list tiles but
I'm only creating them or not as a needs
basis which means that if I have seen a
really long list of data
I only create the appropriate parts that
are being shown on the screen saving a
CPU saving his memory but one of the
great things that Matt mentioned earlier
is that when you're when you have all of
your flutter code has code you get the
ability to turn around and pull out
abstractions and name things so I've got
there's a ListView builder but to me I
really want to call it a store list
which means that my my build method for
my state object now just goes okay I've
got a store list and I've simplified
that complexity so that when I'm reading
this code later I'm not turning around
overloaded with a whole bunch of stuff
and I can't see hide nor hair or what I
was trying to do and the reason I'm
doing this it leads into the next thing
got a list of ice cream stores wouldn't
it be nice to have a map so the first
step obviously import the functionality
now the next one is going to chew up a
bit of a bit of time as my computer
types everything in for me so who here
has done css3 style flex boxes
a couple of you oh good we've got some
web developers so you'll be pleased to
know that oh yeah remember how I said we
had a store list before we went through
I built that I built a matching store
map which is built on top of a Google
map and we'll add some more code to that
in a minute
but the part I'm talking about is here
in the column this column replaces the
earlier thing we're just how to store a
list and because we this column is made
up of too flexibles 40% at the top is
the Google map which is this part here
and 60% down here is our list given that
we have two and three which add up to
five 2/5 3/5 what are you saying 60% so
that's cool I've got a map I'll get a
list of ice cream stores wouldn't it be
nice to actually oh I don't know put
some markers on the map where all the
ice cream stores are fans of ice cream
in the audience excellent boom we have
some ice cream stores so we can click on
them and they've got titles and that's
all good stuff but you know what it'd be
really nice if I could click down here
and go to the actual store ok let's
include some more functionality and this
time I'm including dart async why am i
including dart async ok so what I'm
creating here is the thing called a
completer
the completer is a way of it's an
asynchronous communication channel
because I have an interesting problem in
that I want this list down the bottom
here when I click on it to control the
map and the map gives us a way to do it
a Google map controller but it the map
Google map doesn't give it to us until
after it's on the screen which is too
late to hand it to the ListView
so effectively I'm handling the ListView
this sort of token that says some point
in the future this thing will resolve or
complete to a Google map so let's turn
around and do some more typing and
here's the important part when the map
complete when the map is created we
turn around complete that completer with
a Google map but because I've created
things out of order I just need to
reload my app okay our computer is now
loaded let's turn out and fill in the
store list so we're adding some
functionalities to this abstraction such
that when we tap on one of the list
tiles it will turn around and go to the
latitude and longitude of where that
store is so let's say we want to go to
cream San Francisco yes we're done right
shall we okay let's do two minutes left
it goes what will be really nice we've
got a list of stores would be nice to
use from photos so alongside the name of
the place the location and the street
address I've got a place ID and talking
earlier we mentioned the fact that we
have a whole bunch of community
maintained packages and there's a
package called Google Maps web service
which gives us access to the Google Maps
web service API so in this case I'm
going to be using the places API to look
up information about these are icecream
stores we have things like opening times
reviews all that sort of stuff the part
I'm going to be using is the photos so
the first thing I need to do is of
course refactor things I'm creating a
store list tile that has state so it's
got a stall this tile state and we're
going to turn around and use that to
remember things once we make calls to
places API let's do that now and we'll
turn around and we'll create a Places
API client we'll make requests over I
have to make a quick comment here
because I was the Maps developer
relations for so many use do not put
your Google Maps API key in a production
app don't distribute it when you're
doing quick demos on screen that's okay
don't do it with production just saying
okay because I created the state objects
and then added the unit state
I just need to do a quick reload and
we'll get a whole bunch of photos okay
now we're done right Yeah right no no
I'm gonna do one thing I always one more
thing right thanks Martin
so given the fact that we've created all
these abstractions
we've got list tiles and map Google Maps
and all these sorts of things what I'm
going to do is I'm going to replace the
ListView down the bottom by replacing
just that stall list abstraction with a
store carousel it'll turn the page into
a full-screen map will have a carousel
of tales across the top that we can
click on it's almost finished typing I
love I broke it again so one of the fun
things is because I had this complete
her and I've completed it twice because
I repented the map it's getting Frankie
at me so you won't see this in
production but just because of the way
I've been building it live it now works
so we can turn around and click on it
that's Mission Dolores Park that looks
like pie right to me and now we're done
just does that carousel actually scroll
cuz oh yes yes just most important part
I mean this arrow that's the impressive
piece of your demo and you completely
forgot so that's that's that's really
cool how many lines of code does did
that take in total so let's go back to
the right file this time and less than
250 lines of code
back to the slides so we threw a lot of
code at you there and we went through a
whole bunch of coding pieces but that
was real code that was it actually heart
reloading that was it breaking when
things break and the idea here is is
that we went from like zero to about 150
lines of 200 lines of code having
multiple different representations
showing the composability showing how we
can reuse pieces and showing the power
of things like darts Eastern chronicity
to make it easy to construct and build
these apps because you've seen a lot of
code on there but when you sit down and
you look at it you work through it it's
actually fairly elegant maintainable at
least I think so and readable yes so
hopefully that's given you a little bit
of a flavor for what it's like to work
with flutter and to integrate it in
things like Google Maps there are a
bunch of people much more in this slide
that are using flutter in production in
various ways we are obviously Groupon
Square $0.10
Alibaba all of them are either using
flutter to build 100% dart and flutter
apps or are using flutter inside their
existing apps and there's a wide range
of uses across all of our users but
we're seeing that companies like these
hopefully are trusting the technology
because these things are deployed across
hundreds of millions of devices at this
moment in time around the world so if
this takes your fancy
we highly recommend go to Florida dev
we've got a couple of starting tutorials
if you're new to flutter go and check it
out
see if it's for you and with that we
will open it up for questions thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]